-I really would love it
if I threw out a topic,
maybe we could hear what each of
these characters have to say --
maybe their New Year's
resolutions.
-This camera? Is it camera one?
-Yes. Camera one.
-All right.
-There we go.
Uh, first one, Peter Griffin.
-His New Year's resolution?
-His New Year's resolution.
-[ As Peter] Uh, I'm going to
start by shoplifting
from Wetzel's Pretzels.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wetzel's Pretzels.
-I'm going to shoplift
from Wetzel's Pretzels
because, like,
what are they going to do?
Like, jump over the counter
and kill me for a pretzel?
No. You don't have the guts to
kill me, Wetzel's Pretzels.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
-All right, how about, uh...
[ Chuckles ] Wetzel's Pretzels.
-How about, uh --
how about Stewie Griffin?
-[ As Stewie ] Starting today,
no more diaper.
No more diaper.
I'm going to hold it.
[ Grunts ] Oh.
So, maybe 2025.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He almost did it.
-[ Normal ] He almost got there.
-He almost got there.
Wow. How about Brian Griffin?
-[ As Brian ] Uh, I'm going to
quit smoking and start vaping.
[ Laughter ]
-New year's resolution.
Uh, how about, uh, Quagmire?
-[ As Quagmire ] Uh, I'm going
to get unbanned from Hinge.
All right!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh, how about, uh, Seamus?
-Do you guys even know
who Seamus is?
-Yeah.
-Do you?
The guy with the peg arms
and the peg legs?
How many of you know
who Seamus is?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, wow.
I do not have enough.
faith in this show.
-[ As Seamus ]
I want to get into yoga
so I can stretch my pegs.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you. Seamus.
Uh, how about, uh, Stan Smith?
-[ As Stan ] I'm going to turn
Guantanamo Bay into an Airbnb.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-A good idea.
Uh, how about Roger
from "American Dad!"?
-[ As Roger ]
I'm going to join a gym
so I can do something
about these man boobs.
[ Laughter ]
-And finally, what is
Ted's New Year's resolution?
-[ As Ted ] You know,
I want to travel more
'cause, uh, I've been meaning
to visit your mother's bedroom.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, now!
Who else can do that?
Who else? Seth MacFarlane.
That's unbelievable, buddy.
Thank you for doing that.
[ Normal voice ]
My pleasure, my pleasure.